and after initially appearing calamitous
leap flat-footed the government last
year moved swiftly to legislate in favor
of allowing medicinal cannabis to be
provided in certain cases high-profile
campaigns featuring heartbreaking
stories such as those ability all dwell
and Alfea Dingley gave them little
option compelling medical research
suggests conditions such as epilepsy
Parkinson's disease PTSD severe bowel
conditions and many many other ailments
can be successfully treated using
medicinal cannabis now in some instances
youngsters who can endure up to 100
seizures a day enjoy total respite
therefore this could be chalked up to a
government listening and acting swiftly
for the betterment of its citizens
regrettably no former lecturer Carley
Barton became the first person in the UK
to be prescribed medicine or cannabis
that was on December the 2nd she says
she's still waiting to receive it
next week a documentary on the famous
gogglebox couple DOM and Stephanie
Parker's son Max who is 18 but has a
mental age of six is broadcast and again
experts say the condition he suffered
with since the age of four could be
helped there's no pun intended but isn't
it high time the government provided
rather than promised okay Nick I'm
ambassador for a company who actually
deals of CBD oh okay my interest in it
is the medicinal qualities that it's
helping soldiers with PTSD we're
actually working with soldiers in
Brighton at the moment to see what it
can do yes I do believe that the reason
this has been so screwed in and clamped
down upon is that the the
pharmaceuticals the big ones are
breaking themselves must be fit it's
curing everything we know you don't they
could make it and I'll get into it this
is my second point so the second point
is I do believe that doctors should be
prescribed and experts should be able to
prescribe describe it and I do believe
it should be more widely used yes I also
believe that you have to get the right
quality of stuff now that the company I
represent it's all organic you know is
tested positive ones working with a
soldier what do you see happened to him
or her if it takes out stress this is
not they've taken out the part of this
stuff that's the addictive the part oh
yeah oh where the honking [ __ ] was I
absolutely hate drugs
any capacitor going up your nose that
I'm not smoking I hate the stuff right I
really do
drink this stuff this stuff here is
coming in many forms and it's doing some
great stuff and then the studies been
taken in America and places like that at
the moment suggest this is gonna be a
big thing yeah it's gonna work and it's
gonna help a lot of people and when I
say help a lot of people the soldiers
aren't seen with PTSD is Carmen and down
is taken away the nightmares it's
helping them sleep it's giving them a
better quality life so let's put it out
there do they get hooked nothing to
suggest they get hooked okay but if you
figure that stopping it's gonna give me
a sleep so the change in the law says
that 80,000 specialists doctors are now
licensed to prescribe it but they don't
want to do it and they don't want to do
for one very simple reason this cuz
there's no infrastructure in place to
protect them if it goes wrong so it goes
wrong goes wrong in what work because if
they prescribe it to someone and
something happens to that person because
let's face if they have been and what
these done let me just tell you it's
because these doctors are saying there
have been no medical trials as they're
all with other drugs done on cannabis so
yes while they are saying something
happens it would help mums and let's
have a look at Carley Barton's reaction
yes before I come in on this because she
was delighted when she got a
prescription I'm over the moon oh I'm
overjoyed that this and that this has
happened that this piece of paper exists
it will mean that I am NOT concerned
about having to take consumed my
medicine when I'm out the house I don't
I'm not gonna have to look over my
shoulder to worry if there's police
there security there so like I did with
up West topic I want to broaden this out
of it and say I've been an advocate for
the decriminalization of all drugs I'll
go further
why the view okay on the Portugal model
crime dropped drug at drug-related
deaths fell but to be specific there is
a difference between there is a
difference between decriminalization and
legalization yeah so what I mean by
decriminalization is are people who are
addicted should be treated to the health
system and not through the criminal
justice system as for weed I advocate it
should be legalized and that's where I
think so many scare stories around weed
because when people like you say weed
yeah just up in the sense of the science
the science is quite clear at the moment
with multiple studies done that actually
there is no there are on the adult brain
there are no long term effects before
what can go wrong I tell you what can go
wrong
lots of studies have been done with kids
in particular and the side that's why I
say that all brain nausea vomiting fever
fatigue that's why you don't get so
there are conflicting studies at work
there aren't comply needs to tell you
what the NHS says because allegations
about the NHS not making it available
for easily and the NHS says adds with
any new medicine where there is the need
to build an evidence base the NHS is
normal medicines governance systems
apply and are being used to support good
clinical practice and safe and effective
prescribing for patients while the
evidence base continues to be developed
the decision to prescribe medicinal
cannabis is a clinical decision for
specialist hospital doctors made with
patients and their families to determine
the most appropriate medication or
course of treatment for an individual
patient I think it's important to show
that this isn't just suddenly freely
making kind of it's available to
children everywhere this is a very
anything sorry many safeguards that
people who do have a clinical need for
are struggling to organize freely the
whole word cannabis if you took it out
of that just said there's a new
revolutionary drug that's being
developed that actually helps you you'd
be looking at the completely different
in the fact but you're saying cannabis
you've got this image of somebody I in a
wreath hanging up the face right it's
not that okay they take
all those qualities out with the product
okay in such a way that you don't get
don't get a big to do it you don't get
hooked on it you don't depend on it
let's just go to some family for whom
this is all too real this is Steph and
Don Parker a clip from the Channel 4
documentary can't cannabis save our son
in an ideal world how's that magazine
still hot I'd quite like to be able to
bring those seizures down improve his
quality of life and to be able to have a
conversation with them
and if one or two drops of oil could
take these things out of his body I'd be
the happiest man alive imagine I know
you're itching to get back in on this
between there is research in Australia
that says there can be I do have to say
there are conflicting studies you must
allow that much I have looked into this
indeed ok I can assure you at least but
you will have success there are
conflicting studies around no I don't
know I don't tell you where any asking
the question I'll explain why I don't
okay there's something called old sign
some new science right so more research
has been done since the study that
indicated it may harm the brain all
research has been done what they found
is that on the undeveloped
underdeveloped brain are sort of the
teenage and child brain then it does
affect but on the adult brain it there
are no there is currently no I promise
you on experiment and and and more
importantly more importantly harm is not
a basis to ban anything because alcohol
is more harmful than cannabis smoking is
more harmful to communities so the
assumption that harm itself should mean
that we we don't decriminalize it I
question in the fight so the latest
research shows that the 10% of regular
cannabis users become addicted in and
and yourself who are advocating the use
of it recreational use you can't keep
quoting the Portugal study as it that's
addictive an addiction time a calm but
okay people like you're stuck keep on
quoting this Portugal study okay
the fact is less people are dying of
drugs that because they've opened that
they've got free policy on drugs but
more people are trying drugs like
cannabis than ever before this argument
is on yeah so what
already using lots of other medications
by force which can also have side
effects and and have to carry the risk
of harm so it's not about recreational
use of going from a neutral state to
something that could be harmful it's
about having an illness that requires
medication that has fine a very wide I'm
switching chair this one which maybe has
NHS have you have a policy of testing
every drugs II who uses a medical
tragedy and yet there is no medical
trial on campus well then let's do one
but talking recreational use we need to
take a recreational right